films can be anything so they can do
anything and therefore it's incumbent on
us as filmmakers to try and push
whatever whatever boundaries we can and
not be you know beholden to a to a
theoretical rule set i think that's the
most
strong form of characterization people
can talk about who they are and what
motivates them but you don't trust them
you wait and see what do they actually
do what do they do to each other i think
in various ways all the films i've done
have relied on that film noir
dynamic there's always this this
question of let's judge the characters
based on what they do rather than than
what they say it was about taking this
beloved character
and
recontextualizing the character setting
this extraordinary figure in an ordinary
world or a seemingly ordinary world what
if we try to ground this and really
explain
how this might happen in in a real world
scenario and so i wanted to address the
story very much in the language of
suspense that's the most visual uh
language of a film there is one of the
things we were trying to do in the film
by putting people
as firmly as possible into leonard's
head we were really
trying to make the audience question
their own process of memory a little bit
that was really the challenge in making
inception was to keep everything
grounded to keep everything feeling like
it was possible even as what's happening
in the film is
on some level impossible i try and only
think of the characters as real people
if you start thinking about actors
while you're writing you're gonna
limit what the character can be
[Music]
i've always been fascinated by the the
nature of dreaming the idea that
while we're dreaming we can create a
world but perceive it at the same time
without realizing that we're performing
both those those functions to the extent
where if we dream we're having a
conversation with somebody
we're dreaming that person we're also
creating the words that are in that
person's mouth but we feel we're hearing
them as a for the first time it took me
a long time to write the script because
i based it on this idea of a heist movie
set in the world of dreams the problem
with the heist movie is
they tend to be procedural they tend to
be deliberately superficial and so it
took me a long time to realize that when
you're dealing with a world of dreams
that's not enough you need emotion
and so the central character played by
leonardo dicaprio became
the most important part of making the
story relatable for the audience i uh
thought long and hard about
how you address this enormous story
that's far too big to encompass in a
movie um there's four hundred thousand
people involved
a vast scale of
you know myriad human experiences and
and ultimately what i chose to do
is
focus on the elements that make the
dunkirk story unique
from
just another war film or whatever and
it's the survival aspect
and the suspense aspect and so i wanted
to address the story
very much in the language of suspense
that's the most visual
language of a film there is and so
it leads you towards
an approach stripped down of dialogue
really looking to the visual masters of
the past this kind of storytelling is
what i wanted to do and so you wind up
needing to
fragment the story into broadly speaking
land sea and air these three strands
that you you intertwine over the course
of the film and the reason for that is
i want to tell an intense
intensely subjective version of this
story so i wanted to put the audience on
the beach with the guys who are on the
beach i also want to put them in the
cockpit of a spitfire
with a pilot who's got about an hour's
flying time over over dunkirk and his
dog fighting with the enemy so when
you're cross-cutting these different
timelines
you're
never departing from the subjective
storytelling the human scale
storytelling but you are starting
hopefully to build up a coherent picture
of the larger events that need telling
in any in any version of the dunkirk
story
so everything for me in this film is
about intensity and suspense it's about
trying to stay in a human scale of
storytelling but get across with clarity
the larger movements of the evacuation
i'm very interested in the process of
memory and the way it can be distorted
and all the rest and i know that guy the
same as as me
in going through making the film
you go through we went through an
intense process of questioning
um our own memories and the way it works
and i sort of came out the other side
very much less confident of the way my
memory worked than before
and then the script and leonard systems
and the way the plot points come
together relating to memory they are
just extrapolations of
the way
i try and help my short-term memory
myself
you know i write phone numbers in my
hand and i uh i take notes and you know
i have souvenirs of things and i use
photography and all these different aids
to kind of
you know help me live life and once you
start identifying them
you start to realize that your process
of memory is not as good as you you
hoped and it's much more interpretive
than you realized and one of the things
we were trying to do in the film
by putting people
as firmly as possible into leonard's
head we were really uh trying to to make
the audience question their own process
of memory a little bit the way we did
while we were making the phone i tend
not to think of casting at all when i'm
writing um so while i was rewriting
jonah's script i try and only think of
the characters as real people if you
start thinking about actors while you're
writing you're going to limit what the
character can be do you think of people
you know no no they're just they're just
characters and and that's one of the
great things about writing a screenplays
you know you get to to create in that
way and then when you're finished and
you've taken it as far as you can in the
screenplay form that's when you need
these guys to come on and really make
this do you have a writing process do
you lock yourself in do you write at
night do you tear out your hair
all of the above
i think
what
i've carried with me about about that
experience as far as my own films go
is
really just a sense
that
films can be anything that they can do
anything
uh you know what kubrick did in in 1968
is
he
simply refused to acknowledge that there
were any
rules that he had to play by in terms of
of narrative and and if if there was any
such rule book he threw it out the
window and and went his own way and i
think any filmmaker being inspired by
that as so many filmmakers have been
they carry with them this idea
that movies can do anything
and therefore it's incumbent on us as
filmmakers to try and push whatever
whatever boundaries we can and not be
you know beholden to a to a theoretical
rule set when you talk about dreams you
immediately start to think that the
that world is infinite that anything is
possible
what was interesting about
chris's take on this dream world and
what he was very specific with us about
is that it had its own set of rules
that um you immediately start to talk
about the human subconscious and
entering the dream world and you think
you know we could be flying around in
other galaxies with mystical creatures
and you know insane settings but he
wanted to be very deeply rooted in
things we understood
that was really the challenge in making
inception was to keep everything
grounded to keep everything feeling like
it was possible even as what's happening
in the film is uh on some level
impossible well i i've always been
interested in
that
particular story element or narrative
element you know that of of the
unreliable narrator particularly when
you are given a very strongly that
narrator's point of view
um through the film
um but to me it had always been a
problem to come up with the appropriate
reason for the the narrator being
unreliable because to me it's never been
interesting enough you know if the guy
is just lying or if he's dreaming or you
know whatever um but in this idea of my
brothers i found a sort of perfect
jumping off point to it to explore that
that method of storytelling that that
idea of
seeing the world through this very
distorted point of view
of one particular person
i think i started off in in the
noir genre as we talked about earlier
and that's a genre in which
you define character through action
people can talk about who they are and
what motivates them but you don't trust
them you wait and see what do they
actually do what do they do to each
other
and that's essential to the way that
genre works i think that's the most
strong form of characterization
and
i think in various ways all the films
i've done
have relied on that film noir dynamic
whether it's science fiction you know
like interstellar or inception or action
films like the dark knight trilogy
there's always an underlying film noir
dynamic there's always this this
question of
let's
let's judge the characters based on what
they do rather than than what they say
uh and i've always enjoyed that form of
characterization the original
inspiration behind
the dark knight trilogy and particularly
batman begins
it was about taking this beloved
character
and
recontextualizing the character setting
this extraordinary figure in an ordinary
world or a seemingly ordinary world and
so for me it was much more about
creating a recognizably real
scenario that the extraordinary figure
of batman could exist in and addressing
the origins of that the origin story
which hadn't been told in films before
hadn't really even been addressed in the
comics very specifically actually uh and
so
we were able to really look at that gap
in pop culture and say okay what if we
try to ground this and really explain
how this might happen in in a real world
scenario that was always the jumping off
point for the tone of the film um you
said the tenet brought things that you
had been thinking about for at least 20
years what was the moment you realized
that the script was ready to shoot
well it was more a question of the
moment i realized that the set of ideas
was was ready to commit to the page in
screenplay form um
i won't sit down to write something
until i kind of know that i'm ready to
and the the ideas are all in balance and
that can take a very long time
i'm not somebody who does a lot of
multiple drafts over the years i tend to
just take notes and draw diagrams and
think about concepts and sort of think
about okay how could you apply that to
different
forms of storytelling what might the
screenplay be but once i've kind of
focused in on on
that set of ideas and i know i'm ready
to to put it into screenplay form that's
sort of the big leap for me and then the
screenplay is a sort of jumping off
point for the execution of you know how
you're actually going to go and make it
and so we would stage the scenes in a
very spontaneous way where the actors
knew the dialogue they knew the scene
incredibly well we would go to the
location and they would walk it through
and then i would just follow them with
the camera and i think
that
was the right approach for me and set me
on the path of always thinking about
considering the point of view
of the storytelling where is the camera
why is the camera where it is and so
just
naturally i started off on this journey
that i've continued of always trying to
think in three dimensions not look at um
the shot as a two-dimensional picture
but look at where everything is in
three-dimensional space that's why i
don't use a monitor on set to this day i
just stay by the camera because i want
to see
where things are in three-dimensional
space
and then
place the camera according to my idea of
what the point of view is and i like to
try and align the audience quite closely
with the point of view of a character in
the film that feels the most natural
form of of storytelling to me i think
really the only useful advice i ever got
in terms of
you know trying to figure out your way
in to the film business of film industry
is to
get yourself a script and hang on to it
um
it's that idea
that screenplay that that concept you
know whatever that's going to be
that's so important and
you have to stick to your guns you have
to find something that you can do
that maybe other people couldn't do
and even if that seems different or
doesn't fit into
people's expectations
that's what's going to distinguish it if
you can do it successfully so i think
it's really about sticking to your guns
and
you know doing something you
passionately believe in rather than
trying to appeal to some desire that you
imagine other people have for what they
want to see in a film i think you have
to be true to your own passion and your
own sense of what excites you as a
storyteller you have to play to your
strengths you have to do something that
really excites you and whatever's
different about that in the case of
following the non-linear structure was a
somewhat unusual choice
but it's those things that are the
strength of the project
it's the things that you can bring
to what you're doing or bring to the
filmmaking craft that maybe not
everybody else is doing maybe not
everybody else can do or has thought to
do that's what's going to distinguish
the thing so it might seem
in some ways more difficult or seem like
something that would make the project
more difficult to to sell when it's
finished you know what what have you but
for me i think the answer was definitely
to try to play to my strengths and the
things that i personally
uh was passionate about
but but very much at the time i felt
very young and very inexperienced and i
felt that
my own life and the things i saw in the
world were not going to be of interest
to people
but they felt interesting to me and so i
was looking for a language i was looking
for a genre in which i could take
things that i was interested in
and make them accessible make them
interesting to other people and i think
that the crime genre the filmmaker and i
think that's the way it works it's
characters are defined through action
double cross things they're doing to
each other your particular fears about
whatever it is your life your
relationships or whatever those things
are the best filmoir has always been
very firmly founded on on those
relatable fears no i
i i love working with with family and
friends and people you work with a long
time i mean emma is my
you know my longest and closest
collaborator and she's produced in
various forms all of the films i've done
[Music]
it's great to be able to work with
people who don't have any
agenda
other than
helping you make the best film that you
can
[Applause]
and
it's surprising how difficult it is to
forge those relationships um
in a business context and so
where you've had the pleasure of working
with people were
money and business everything wasn't
even a part of what you were doing uh
it's wonderful if you're able to hang on
to those relationships and so there are
a lot of people like the composer david
julian who worked with for years who's a
friend from from college uh you know the
various people like that who i work with
i work with
the director of photography wally fister
for many years and memento was the first
film we did together which was a very
small film
there's an ease of communication that
develops and there's a trust
and you know when people are around you
who
only really want the best for the film
and you and you know that
when they tell you
you're wrong or you're doing something
stupid or you know you should lower the
tone of your voice or whatever they
happen to be telling you uh you tend to
pay attention i think working in in
films
today it's an era where people tend to
watch films more than once even if they
don't like them you know you'll see it
in the cinemas first release perhaps and
then you'll see it on
you know cable television television
you're watching an airplane or in a
hotel room or something or it winds up
eventually on on
regular tv
and so
i think my generation of filmmakers
understood where there's a
responsibility to try and
make something that has layers something
that has
more to it the second time you see it or
some different aspect to it and i chose
to take the
path of
incorporating that desire for for a
layered approach into the narrative
itself into the story if you like and so
i've made films that have some ambiguity
them or some
layering to them narratively so that if
you see them a second time you're going
to watch them in a slightly different
way and that was that was my approach
there are other filmmakers who
approached it from a purely visual point
of view where they would just create
very dense visuals that would sustain
multiple viewings because you'd sort of
see more in the frame
i mean for me
the only sincerity
in filmmaking is to make a film that you
would want to go see yourself
and not treat the audience as anything
separate from from
from you
our expectations when we go to see a
film are different in different genres
and at different budget levels and that
that doesn't mean we're
dumber when we go see a bigger film or
you know but we do have a different
expectations it's a different register
of language in a sense i've always found
dreams to be
a very uh inspiring uh part of my life
uh i think the
the idea that has always fascinated me
about dreams is the realization that
everything within that dream is created
by your own mind
as you experience it and it's that
peculiar relationship between the
creative part of imagining a world
imagining someone talking to you
and then the realization that as you
absorb that world you're not aware of
the fact that you've actually created it
so if you're talking to somebody in a
dream you're supplying both halves of
that that conversation but you seem to
be experiencing just from one half
and i think that what that says about
the
potential of the human mind is quite
extraordinary and inception is intended
to be a film that
that
tries to explore the exciting
possibilities of what that says about
the human mind and the infinite
potential of the human mind
and so the structure i settled on is one
that
it's based on a musical structure called
the shepherd tone which is a a musical
illusion whereby you can keep climbing
up the scale it's something i'd used in
my schools like the david julian school
for the prestige was the first time we
experimented with it so you're
continually going up the scale going up
the scale but you never seem to go out
of out of reach if you like and i wanted
to try and apply that to screenwriting
to a narrative and say okay with this
story
can you braid together the three
storylines in such a way that you create
the idea of a continuing rise in
intensity narratively
and sustaining that
is the challenge of the structure
and the way in which i approach
different or complex structures as i
have in the past
um and and i do with this film is you
diagram it you you
get a hold of it mathematically so you
know exactly what it's meant to be doing
but then you sit down and you write the
script from page one right through to
the end of the film the way the audience
is going to be receiving that
information the hope is that in that way
you're actually creating a cohesive and
organic
rhythm and story movement built on
a very
constructed
you know set of of parameters but
not through
cutting and pasting not creating a
fractured narrative so much as
uh disparate story threads that braid
together to make one you know coherent
story i've always loved the spy genre i
grew up watching the james bond films
and
you know
later on the born films and you know the
john le carre and all of these these
great
um
representations of espionage in fiction
and the uh escapist component to that i
think is a big part of that for me
cinematically what the spy film always
allowed was the idea of international
travel the idea of the glamour being
able to go
places in the cinema that you'd never be
able to go in real life
and have access to all kinds of
extraordinary situations that you get to
enjoy by proxy and that's very much what
we tried to bring to tenet but we tried
to do it
with an added science fiction component
we tried to do it with
um
a concept that would allow audiences to
approach this in a fresh way
uh
for me tenet really is about taking the
uh the elements of of spy fiction and
and particularly cinematic you know spy
fiction and having having new reason to
look at them in a different way taking
them and turning them on their heads
really it wasn't conscious on my part to
to
have another script sort of ready to go
by the time we
went to film festivals with following
while we were finishing up the cart on
it and doing
very long slow technical finishing uh
which when you have no money takes
forever because you're sort of waiting
for the lab to have a
you know run the 16mm bath you know
whatever it is um in that time i was
putting together the script for momentum
and so
uh
also in the time it took to get
following noticed on the festival
circuit so get out there i had actually
finished the script and in retrospect
it was a massive advantage because i was
able to say okay you like that film
this is what i want to do next because
in your best case scenario of what
can happen to you with putting a film
out there and getting distribution for
example um
you're then asked the question okay what
do you want to do next if you have an
answer
you can use that very short window of
interest that you get from people in
what you've done
you